[Music]
so look again shout out to pod boy he
has just been uncovering so much stuff
yeah pod boys like on Bluetooth
this is from 2015. Paulie Shore was the
guest on tigerbelly put it this way the
only people that I truly like
that I know through you or your brother
Steve is like a brother to me okay I
like Charlie let's play a game though
okay one through ten okay okay this
isn't healthy I don't care one through
ten okay okay
Paulie Shore
oof you went early there
um probably a negative 86. oh
okay I get what you're saying that's a
zero just say zero a zero Bobby
literally said just go to zero let's go
to zero okay I would helpful advice with
Bobby collider now remember she was
talking [ __ ] about Paulie Shore okay two
years later Paulie short comes on the
show
and Paulie Shore
I'm a 27 year old male who is really
lost in life I have a dead-end job still
live with my parents one which has stage
four cancer I have no real friends and
have never actually had a real
girlfriend I would say that things
aren't really going well for me I'm very
socially awkward and shy not talented or
intelligent in any way I wouldn't say
I'm good looking but by any means
overall I would say I'm a loser I grew
up Christian and all I hear from people
around me is trust in God and I feel as
though everyone around me is moving up
in life and getting married and being
promoted at work also I don't have a
real passion for anything anyways what
should I do
you know what I mean I've had a lot of
girlfriends that I've been with that
were not faithful to me he was
just worthy when I first met him
it's always just throwing them under the
bus
by the way why is she talking to Paulie
Shore why isn't he this is so weird this
feels like I'm watching like like a
cuckold situation like but they're on a
date but they're all cuckold
or not faithful to me he wasn't
trustworthy when I first met him
just dude
I'm gonna and she was I'm pushing this
isn't this I'm pushing this Theory
because we've talked about it the other
day
I believe that she is the person
that the tigerbelly email that sent
Brennan into a spiral encounter spiral I
believe she was the person doing that
stuff oh yeah I no proof I have no proof
no I I made that up in my head and I'm
like yeah that's I'm going with that
because it makes the most sense it's
perfect yeah it's just it fits her man
at all yeah but were you trustworthy
I by the time he said I love you we want
I want to be in a committed relationship
absolutely yeah there was nothing and I
don't have you ever felt any type of way
about it turns to Bobby to defend her
good good catch by the way popcorn
like straying no
now leads to this so remember our Theory
so this is from um
to this is from uh too lazy to try check
this out this they just sent me this
like while we were live
do we have Brendan chab's assistant
slash Handler Mark or most people know
him as bgl the guy recently decided on
his Instagram rant trashing kalila and
this actually isn't the first time he's
gone after her during all the drama I
remember this is the same Mark Carly
that got uh Brendan's whiskey brand
kicked off of Instagram
smart good good play he kept taking
shots at her and also he's gone after
Theo too on Instagram so this guy just
cannot control himself yeah yeah did you
know saw Mark Carly's been going after
Theo too Mark Harley because Brendan I
guarantee you has been complaining about
Theodore Mark Carling complaining about
kalilah and Mark Harley's like don't
worry bro you can't talk [ __ ] but I can
guaranteed oh he's doing well that's
that's always been the theory that we
had is that he uses him as his proxy yep
and I'm sure Brennan's not too happy
about this because he just wants to be
drama-free it sounds like but bgl on the
other hand it looks like he wants to go
back to war with Bobby and kalila so
this is what he had to say on Instagram
a few months ago I stated this person is
a narcissistic sociopath in a reply
comment on my own post and people
screenshotted it and posted it all over
Reddit as if it was a wild accusation
that reflected poorly on me I got to
know my first sociopath at 16 and have
had significant interactions with a
small handful sense I've never made an
incorrect assessment of a sociopath and
would only make a public accusation like
this if I felt like I had sufficient
information to make that claim
accurately and also and I'm hearing it
in big bgl's voice too so I'm already
because yes so that it's in the public
interest to do so because it's not
obvious as yet to everyone around that
person watch these videos and tell me I
was wrong so I thought this post was
just hilarious for a number of reasons
so what he Mark Harley posted xlp
posted xlp's video the one that we
played yet the one that we played
yesterday oh yes so that's that's what
I'm seeing here that's that looks like
what he's referring to saying see kalila
look and we agree be a big gay lion
kalila's associate she's crazy but that
doesn't mean you're not cringe bro that
doesn't change anything yeah you're
still cringe but we agree with you about
this one thing yeah I like how he's
calling out kawala for being a
narcissist but yet this whole post is
just all about him and how he can
accurately diagnose somebody as a
narcissist but maybe he's too lazy to
try on fire bro by the way may subscribe
real good by the way too lazy to try is
great because even this voice reflects
his name exactly I got all this
information but like oh I don't even
care about it I don't even know why I
know this stuff
he rules man I love him he puts in the
work I'll give him that be able to do
that because he's one as well and
unfortunately there is some truth to
what he's saying here I mean if you
watch these videos that you linked it
does make Lyla look like she is just out
of control but I feel like it's a pretty
stupid idea for bgl to be posting this
because I think it'll only hurt The
credibility of these videos because like
I said Mark's not the most sane person
out there and I'm sure people would
describe him as this stuff too and also
people might think that this channel
might be working with Brendan or Mark
possibly plus there's not much he's
adding to it I mean I don't think he's
gonna bring it I don't think xlp is
working with Brendan or Mark xop no I
think he's saying that it's going to
create that impression oh oh okay yeah I
misunderstood okay yeah because because
honestly you're saying that Mark sharing
it hurts that channel because right oh
now people have good words good point so
now xop's gonna have to make it being
like hey you suck too [ __ ] yeah in that
many views to these videos and the video
is already doing really well themselves
I mean 73 000 views after 19 hours in
this channel you're welcome only has 4
kidding by the way 4.5 000 Subs I mean
that's really good these videos are
taken off Mark isn't going to add
anything to that so I think if he really
wants to see kalila get exposed it's
better off if he just I think a lot of
people have seen kalila get exposed
out of it also this isn't a good look
because most of the star she jerks off
dogs
started when they called out kalila for
like harassing or like cyber bullying
Brendan on the internet and now Mark's
posting this kind of stuff it's just not
going to be a good look for Brendan and
also during the tiger belly podcast that
Brendan was on koala brought up Mark and
she said can you tell him to like knock
it off he keeps going after me and no
look you know we should do this is a
really good one so in this entire
situation and I'm asking this because
we've covered them all we've made fun of
them all whatever in this entire
situation out of okay
Bobby Lee
kalila
Brennan Schaub
Brian Callan and big gay lion
who do you think is the worst kalila
kalila right I mean he's easy right
diseasing right absolutely absolutely an
easy question like it's it's not even
it's not even close
these League's worse than them too it's
not even like like yeah she's [ __ ]
horrible
um you know what I'm gonna I I rarely
use this function and by the way Rumble
you should add this we already told him
to add this but I I'm gonna put I'm
gonna put a um
I'm gonna put a poll up
and we'll see what the we'll let you
know what the chat has to say while we
keep playing this
Brennan said he told him to take it easy
because he's only making things worse in
the next coming weeks however I'm
starting to see screenshots on Instagram
of VMS of um your cute little friend
Mark confirming that you wanted to
expose me is that correct
well no I went to Mark and said dude
you're making things way worse from okay
because he's trying to defend me I went
you're not defending me you're making it
worse giving her Fuel and me and her
talking you don't need to do this so
with this new post from bgl I wonder if
he got Brendan's permission for it or
anything I mean I'm sure by the way
after everything big gay lion does it's
only because it's a it's Brendan's
allowing it yeah it serves up the
pleasure of Brendan right exactly doubt
it because I doubt Brandon will give him
permission to do this because I'm sure
it's only going to hurt Brendan
zimbabies he's the hand job of the king
relationship even more and it seemed
like they're kind of maybe starting to
patch things up possibly but if Mark's
gonna do this [ __ ] then I'm sure it's
gonna just make things worse and also it
just makes Mark quickly an idiot because
nobody takes him seriously to begin with
and also it's just hilarious that he's
calling someone out for being a
narcissist when he's the one just adding
himself into all this drama and making
it all about himself and that because I
can't imagine Brendan's okay internet
but he is but he absolutely is and you
know what it's too late too lazy to try
you sound like a real ass type person
we're n-type people around here we're
dead the least we live like end times we
encourage our listeners to get drugs
illegally and hormones illegally on the
internet through the dark web yeah
that's us that's us too lazy come on bro
and one more just a little just a little
cherry on top
this is uh kalila kiss Bobby Lee's
producer
at the end of the most recent bad
Friends episode it was brought up that
Bobby's producer one of his producers
who's also I think a person she's an
avatar I love it it's great apparently
used on the podcast and koala kissed him
so obviously Bobby wasn't too happy
about that but it's hard to tell how
upset he was because I'm sure some
people say he's playing it up for
entertainment purposes but it does sound
like Lila might have a thing for this
guy Carlos I think his name is so she is
kissing somebody else that works with
Bobby
imagine Bobby's pretty upset about this
because also she did it with a guy that
he knows that he's friends with that
works for him and I'm sure they've known
each other for a while and also klyla
had some very positive things to say
about him so I think this is definitely
disrespectful one where cloud
I got peer pressures and what
put the mic near your mouth I want to
hear you say it I want to hear you say
yeah peer pressured and what
it was just a little and what there's
this little dab on like tongue if this
is kalila it looks like her it would
just be this
okay I want to watch the video
and if it's not that it is that be
honest with you right now I'm this is my
one chance to tell the truth yeah yeah
so like La comedy L.A comedy podcaster
is just a series of people emasculating
each other
over and over again I don't understand
this like
it seems like all the comedy comes from
how sad they are instead of New York
comedy podcasts with all that comedy
comes with how much drugs they're on yes
which I prefer by the way yes in every
way because that's [ __ ] fun you know
I'm gonna say something right now I kind
of want to take a walk from playing with
fire that's the last pack you get no no
no no no no
no no how do I get this show run for not
long right like they just kept pairing
these people together I think this
Show's so fun this Show's still good
yeah bad friends yeah
do not let it go yeah you're right do
not hold it in in now warehouses for
podcasters that look like those old cam
horror warehouses they used to have
that's what this is man
yeah there it is
you Mexican beasts of [ __ ] yeah hit him
hard hit him harder yeah that's not
enough hit him hard you balding mediocre
there you go that's great right get it
going lazy hit him hard
um and I know Bobby's trying to be funny
and I understand what he's doing here
but you still look really bad in this
like you know
yeah I don't know if he's got like a
humiliation fetish or something you know
what joking aside bro he actually might
some people do you know where they get
off on that